hello everyone and welcome back to round
seven of the 20/20 candidates tournament
it's a former vultures championship
challenger Fabiana Caruana versus van
kala and before we check out the game
here's a nice photo of the two of them
there you have it Bobby with his bottle
of water and among how again with with
his banana probably not gonna just eat
it up right away maybe maybe in the fort
or maybe fifth hour of game plate to get
that extra boost needed for four to play
in in game against Bobby but we'll see
it's it's hard to say so without further
ado let's check it out Bobby with the
white pieces opens with E 4 and s wrong
how already there I said in his previous
games with the black pieces against the
fort he prepared the petrol for this
candidates tournament we had Knight to
f3 sorry about that
and Knight to f6 the petrov is on the
board and Knight captures on e5 going
for the classical variation these six
Knight to f3 and mountain Knight
captures on e4 and here Fabi goes for
the names of each attack with the Knight
to c3 which is my favorite line against
against the better of so I'm very happy
about this Knight captures and see 3d
characters and Bishop to e7 and if there
are some beginners watching I always
like to mention that sometimes if black
goes Bishop to g4 you can immediately
punish this with h3 and after the bishop
moves just go for a nice double attack
here which will win you the bishop pair
because you now have the character
capture and now well obviously block the
b7 square and now you have an open game
with two bishop so you will have you
will have a great time but ok Bishop to
e7 vivanco and now Bishop to e3
i we have castles by monk ow and now
Queen to d2 preparing to Castle
queenside Knight to d7 and now a
queenside castle story about that night
to have 6 and Bishop to d3 now
developing the bishops to d3 in d3
like Paul Morphy and now c5 c5 creating
this week the soft well for the moment
we see six pawn but he's preparing Queen
to a5 to go after the Queen side here we
look HD 1 and now Bishop to e6
I just going after the pawn
King Tubby one defending and now Queen
to a5 and the fog we read you
disposition a couple of times for
example he had it last year against Duda
in the Grantchester in in the Paris
rapid tournament where he played a three
not to nullify this threat and he
defeated Duda in this game but he also
had this position in his game against
Magnus Carlsen only constant had the
white pieces of course and then that
story about that and in that game as c4
was played by Carlson and this is what
Fabi goes for here he follows the game
crossing against Khurana from the 2018
World Chess Championship match we have
Queen captures and e2 and now Bishop
captures and e2 was played in every game
that reached this position including the
one cross and versus Khurana from the
World Chess Championship match in 2018
but here Fabi goes for Knight captures
and e2 and this is the deviation that
Fabi prepared
probably to try and throw the Ivanka of
guard so it is as a move for team that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how the game continues how of course
now that the Queen's are off the board
now d6 could become could become a
weakness so rook a to d8 he wants to
prepare and bust open the position with
d5 we have Knight to f3 a story not
Knight to f3 f3 by Fabienne de now b6
strengthening the c5 pawn so you can put
d5 and now g4 is f3 prepared that you
want to go g4 and g5 we have d5 striking
in the center and now g5 saying that you
don't have time to continue pushing
because of characters and captures so
Knight has to move whether to EA d7 or
h5 e 8 and h5 is great at d7 not so much
because you block off your rooks
influence along the D file so nice the
h5 but it's all in preparation for
pushing f5 and you are expecting capture
some poisson so the knight will return
right back so that's it's the knight
will not stay on the edge of the board
for long we have see captors on d5 now
Bishop captures and now Knight to e4 and
here by blocking the bishops attack on
the f3 pawn this is where
how goes f5 and of course now if you
move the night for example you move the
night you just capture capture and pick
off df3 point so of course Fabi not
eager to allow that G captures on f6 on
Poisson night captures on f6 and now
Bishop to g5 saying now you cannot trade
because Bishop captures here will come
with an attack on both of your looks so
King to f7 now the King also helps out
with the defense of the bishop and only
now Knight to g3 asking one how are you
interested in a nice juicy f3 point here
and indeed if the point is captured it's
well it's a very interesting game for
example if Bishop captures you get
Knight to f5 now offering Rupe for Rupe
captures on e7 and now you have to block
with rook F te8 and then we just run
pretty much trade everything captures
captures captures captures but if you go
for Bishop captures and d1 then it's
then it's really bad for black captures
you have to go here characters with
check you have to go here then you
capture here and then you have insane
pressure against the h7 square and could
be could be a lot of problems for black
so Vanko not interested in capturing the
pawn well at least not yet
he goes for c4 instead he frees the c5
square for his bishop so the knight and
fi will not be such a such a problem
this should be back to f1 and now b5
strengthening his pawn here we have a 4
5 immediately goes after the b5 pawn and
a 6 8 captors and b5 a captures and now
Knight to f5 but now of course the c5
square has been freed for the bishop and
here monk how goes Bishop to c5 if
you're wondering about Bishop to b4 with
an attack on the roof it does seem
better but it's it's pretty much the
same and here's why because now you
either go rook to e5 or you block with
Bishop to d2 but whichever you do after
captures on f3
we pretty much go into a capture fest
and it runs into an equal endgame for
example captures captures now you
capture here attacking the bishop and
now after Luke d1 check King gay - you
capture on f1 white characters here and
it's equal material
the game continues and on the other hand
after Bishop to b4 if you block with
Bishop to d2 then it's again Bishop
captures here you pick off the bishop
now Bishop captures and d1 and now
Knight to d6 with check checking the
King hoping to pick off the bishop with
rook captures here but now rook captures
here and now Bishop captures we have
Bishop rook to b8 now attacking the
bishop and after rook captures here it
seems like white is up a piece but
Knight to e4 you cannot move the bishop
because of rook captures rook so it
seems a monk how could have won upon
here but not really because here Bobby
would have Bishop captures on c4 with
check and now you want pin with rook to
f1 check King e6 and now you bring the
bishop back again having this position
where Fabi has a bishop against tonight
and it's a three point Z each although
evanka with a much more active King so
black black should be preferred here but
after Knight to f5 like I said one cow
went for Bishop to c5 instead and now
Fabi goes for rook the e5 now if this
Bishop moves you can just win the Bishop
on c5 but it's not a problem as the rook
on D 1 is now undefended so Bishop
captures on f3 now again we go into a
capture fest
with rook captures on the 8th route
captors and e8 and now rook captures on
c5 temporarily winning a piece but rook
to d1 with check King to a2 and now rook
captures on f1 rook captures on b5 and
now we get this position the material is
equal but fabi's position is somewhat
shake here we have the immediate c3 the
immediate c3 saying you either double
your pawns and then those are just super
weak points or you play b3 and then my
rook f2 is incredibly strong attacking
both h2 and see two pawns and after you
defend a little at least this pawn with
93 I bring another attacker Bishop b4
and now if King b1 if you persist on
defending then I capture this guy here
and now I'm definitely better as I'm up
upon and you've done nothing so far with
your moves
so after this C to remove we have bushel
characters on f6 King captures on f6 and
now Knight the e3
preemptively defending the sea-doo pawn
rook to f2 attacking the pawn here and
now well you could go for a lot of moves
here b4 seems like seems like good try
for Fabi creating a past beep on and now
it's just a matter of moving your rook
and continuing to push her pawn but
that's easier said than done
now because well black has to be careful
not to move the rook due to rook the f5
check winning the bishop so you can have
to play g6 and then after let's say King
b3 and now you pick off the pawn here
and now you play let's say Ruby 8 and
start pushing your pawn but now it's
black also has a passed pawn and black
they still up upon so if you don't have
a sure sure sure thing here you don't
want to go into an endgame being down
upon
so instead Fabi first goes rook to f5
with Czech king to e6 and now King to a3
again if you if you try and rush with
this b4 movie run into a similar
variation after g6 and now again what do
you do here rook to f4 keeping an eye on
the bishop so the rook cannot move but
now you allow the advancement of the
Jeep on g5 look at five we're gonna go
g4 and you've already allowed this pawn
to come all the way here if you continue
pushing the pawn rook e2 just wins the
game as you're attacking the defender of
the rook here and there is not much to
be done here so it's a it's a very
tricky position so Fabi instead went for
King to a3 he gets away the King away
from the second-ranked and now basically
says okay now you have to capture on V 2
which one how does we have King captures
now and now we have h5 by one cow there
is a there is a move that kind of allows
the wrong how to to maybe go for go for
something more but it's it shouldn't
yield more than a draw but if you're if
you're interested feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea yeah
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting how to
win a pawn and for those who just want
to enjoy a show it's a rook captures and
c2 our point is that if Knight captures
you just play team captures and you have
a
winning chances here because your king
and Bishop are very active and his King
is all the way on b2 you do have a lot
of time to start pushing those pawns and
after look at first and c2 you of course
don't capture with the night you capture
with the king then Bishop e4 check King
to d2 and Bishop captures on f5 now it's
a bit of a different idea as the King y
think is much more active but again with
perfect play it shouldn't yield more
than a draw but that's why you are in
the candidates tournament that you
should you should exploit all of the
options and and hope for the best
because only only black can be better
here but among how first played h5 he
wants the first advance his pawns as far
as he can maybe even all the way to age
3 and then go for this row captors and
c2 idea so his pawns will be more far
advanced but now Fabi blocks it with h4
and here now that one call pretty much
depleted all of the resources now he
goes for rook captures uncie too far
because King captors and c2 we have
disrupted efore with King to d2 and now
Bishop captures on f5 of course you
cannot trade it would be losing endgame
for white to two points against one easy
game so after Bishop captures on a
five-wheel King - E - and now we have
kinked he five with King 2f 3 by Fabi
and after Bishop to d3 it was in this
position that Fabiana Caruana and one
cow agreed to a draw because it in fact
is the draw with perfect play but and
wonho is not interested in in trying
even trying to to do something about
this maybe if you if it was a night for
one cow and the bishop for Fabi then
maybe he would try to do some sneaky
sneaky moves with the night but this way
it's it's fairly easier to draw sure
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
really it was a it was it seems like it
was a pretty safe game for one cow
especially with the black piece against
Fabi and it was very brave of him to go
into the variation the Fabi played
against Magnus in the World Chess
Championship match but also a
it's interesting that that Fabi has an
improvement on that game for white so
which he which he showed in this game
and there was some poison at our
position but one cow just outmaneuvered
or all of the ideas and here for those
of you who are interested I will now
show the standings after round seven so
for those of you who are still under
interested in the standings you know
don't watch close your eyes for a couple
of seconds and for those of you who are
interested here it is because Maxie
Marshall de Graaff defeated the onion
pony she he two of them now share first
place with four and a half and then a
lot of people with three and a half
Fabiano caruana and if you hear even how
Alexander Grisham and with two and a
half at England Akira Alec Cinco and
these are the standings after seven
rounds so we are done with first half of
the tournament now we go into the second
half where all the players will again
face each other with colors reversed so
there's gonna be also very interesting
and you know those who lost to some
players will have their chance to get
their revenge and it's not at the end of
the world for dingen alex angkor format
for example if if they win just one game
they're already on three and a half and
you know it's the ball starts rolling
and it's it wouldn't be unheard of for
ding - maybe when two in a row but with
with the way he's playing so far it
doesn't doesn't he's not getting a lot
of chances and he should win some games
because if he continues in this fashion
or you know he's just gonna ruin the
tournament for Fabi by by defeating him
but yeah like I said I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank you Bob
Karen kill each Erica Fong understand or
ell and yawns yen Stefan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
fede candidates tournament 2020 until it
finishes so thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day